when the first trailer from the ninth
fast and furious film dropped at the
fast nine Festival in Miami on January
31st fans in the nearly two decades long
action franchise were gifted a shocking
surprise after winning over audiences in
2006's The Fast and the Furious Tokyo
Drift on Lu the effortlessly cool street
racer thief businessman and former
member of Dominic Toretto's crew is back
from the dead played by Sung Kang he
died in the third fast and furious movie
the first in the franchise directed by
Justin Lin though he appeared in the
next three films the sagas timeline put
his death after the events of Fast &
Furious 6 the spans have believed for
more than a decade that Hans fate and
the universe had been sealed time for
you to go do
[Music]
her dad done some crazy in Tokyo
yet there he is in the trailer
characteristically snacking as he enters
a room full of his former crewmates this
of course begs a question how is Hans
still alive after audiences saw him die
we got this covered claims to know the
answer take the following with a grain
of salt but the outlet alleges that Hans
simply escaped his car before it became
enveloped in flames unidentified and
unverified sources close to the outlet
say that Han has been in hiding staying
under the radar of those he knows with
the after and following the fateful
incident the sites also reported that
the character will make an appearance in
the sagas tenth and final film slated
for an April 20-21 release however Han
Liu makes his long-desired return in f9
the news of his survival has been a shot
of adrenaline to the fan base of the
fast franchise after being with each
other for more than a decade the cast is
evolved into a family as much as the
characters have han was a huge part of
that which helped convince director
Justin Lin to bring the character back
into Dom's family and back into the fast
universe as Lin told Entertainment
Weekly I think it's really up to us to
bring him back and explore it throughout
the themes that were all used to the
Vans certainly seem happy on Twitter the
announcement that Han would return got
the hashtag Han is a live trending it
also appeared to renew the trust of Fast
diehards who felt betrayed by the movies
after he gave Hans killer Deckard Shaw
prime billing in two films following the
popular characters death as it happens
Lin has a long history with Han since
the character is first introduced in
Lin's 2002 crime drama feature debut
better luck tomorrow
actor Sung Kang revealed in a 2013
interview with mandatory that Han was
added to the Fast and Furious franchise
only after Lin convinced executives to
change up another proposed character
clearly Han is not only beloved by the
fast fandom he's also a character Lin is
carried with him throughout his career
han is a prime example of the narrative
the Fast and Furious saga has built
around found family and that may be
important going into the next film Lin
is certainly not treating the characters
return lightly you told Entertainment
Weekly in this world I feel like things
happen for a reason I won't go into
details or anything but I do think that
bringing him back is nothing I take
lightly and it took a lot but I think
what I appreciate is that this universe
has really grown and it allows us to
evolve and really
to redefine ourselves as we go as han
himself would say I'm simple you make
choices and you don't look back as for
some Kang the experience of returning to
the screen is the fan-favorite is as big
for him as it is for the fans who had
desperately wanted to see him back he
told the Los Angeles Times it's
emotional it feels like I'm going back
to a family reunion it's a relationship
that has been missing in my life since
the last fast see Han Liu make is
long-awaited return when f9 drives into
theaters on May 22nd check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]